Millionen von menschen hat das apollo-programm diesen großen traum erfüllt und
das obwohl es so schien als hätten die usa den wettlauf um die vorherrschaft im all schon lange verloren
ihr habt euch dieses wirklich sehr sehr spannende thema bei was apple gewünscht danke dafür
bekommt jetzt die vier wichtigsten facts zum apollo programm wie genau lief die krasse aufholjagd im weltall ab hat die
apollo-mission überhaupt stattgefunden und welche
tragödien mussten auf dem langen weg zum erfolg verkraftet werden also herzlich willkommen bei pixum science fiction
61 eroberung des weltraums ein spannender wettlauf mit
aufholjagd kein weltraum projekt wird der menschheit mehr eindruck hinterlassen us präsident john f kennedy
hatte beim entwurf des apollo-programms eine große vision dabei wurde der weltraum in mehreren etappen
erobert und den ersten teil hatten die usa jedenfalls gegen die sowjetunion verloren und zwar zum zweiten mal
sputnik der erste satellit war
1957 von den russen gestartet worden und der sowjetunion gelang es auch den ersten menschen ins all zu schicken
1961 war das der kosmonaut juri gagarin
also sah es lange so aus als seien die amerikaner bis aufs letzte
abgehängt der weltraum war zu dieser zeit tatsächlich der schauplatz an dem das ultimative kräftemessen der beiden großmächte
ausgetragen wurde die großen fragen wer schafft es als erster nach oben während als erstes seine flagge in den mondboden
in seiner rede vor dem amerikanischen kongress im mai 1961 kam noch einmal der letzte am sport vom amerikanischen präsidenten
himself
zitat
unsere nation sollte sich verpflichtet fühlen vor dieser dekade einen mann zum mond zu bringen und sicher wieder zurück auf die erde
den amerikanern setzte er damit seine große vision ins ohr die landung der menschen auf dem mond und damit war das apollo-programm
geboren zwei perfekt größte trägerrakete
weltweit deutsche luftwaffe war beteiligt vor allem die entwicklung einer leistungsstarken
trägerrakete stand im fokus der amerikanischen pläne unter steuerte auch die deutsche luftwaffe ihr wissen hinzu
die herausforderungen die trägerrakete musste der erdanziehung entkommen und ein bemanntes raumschiff in den weltraum befördern das endergebnis
die saturn 5 die mit ihrer höhe von
110 metern noch immer zu den größten raketen der welt gehört gerade habe ich sehr als bausatz von lego gebaut das ist schon ziemlich
fasziniert ihre leistung ist tatsächlich phänomenal ihr startgewicht lag bei
2.880 tonnen das dreistufige trägersystem hatte eine schubkraft von haltet euch fest
160 millionen ps und die saturn 5 erreicht eine spitzengeschwindigkeit von
39.000 kilometern pro stunde und so dauert es nur 60 stunden bis die
trägerrakete die astronauten zum mond gebracht hatte
das absolut paradoxe der großteil des gewichtes war dazu da das große gewicht der rakete nach oben zu befördern
fast ein fliehendes ziel aber am ende
schaffte es die rakete raumschiff und mondlandefähre zum mond zu bringen ein bruchteil des gewichtes an sich bestand das apollo raumschiff aus drei komponenten
im kommando module waren die instrumente
angesiedelt um es zu steuern hier lebten die astronauten auch sie aßen und schliefen beispielsweise hier das haupttriebwerke und die elektrischen systeme
sowie die kommunikationszentrale befanden sich im service modul in der mond lande einheit hatten zwei astronauten platz
damit konnte man auf der mondoberfläche
landen und auch wieder zum kommando modul zurückkehren dritter effekt nur 17 der geplanten 20 missionen fanden statt
der start des apollo programms war im jahr
1967 mit apollo 1 insgesamt zwölf probe für gewann geplant bis der erste astronaut
tatsächlich auf dem mond landen sollte und der anfang vom ganzen wurde tatsächlich zur tragödie drei astronauten sollten einen monat vor dem ersten flug der
apollo-11-mission die raumkapsel testen doch die ingenieure hatten eine technische schwachstelle
übersehen einige werfen der nasa sogar vor im rennen um die erste mondlandung
nachlässig geworden zu sein es gab ein feuer im cockpit die
sauerstoffversorgung der raumanzüge fiel aus die drei männer verbrannten mit der apollo 8 gelang dann später die erste bemannte
mond umrunden und apollo 11
beinhaltete dann endlich die erste mondlandung doch anfang der 70er jahre
drehte sich die stimmung der amerikaner hinsichtlich des apollo-programms aber bis dahin hatte die nasa auch schon sechs
erfolgreiche mondlandung hinter sich und so wurde das budget der weltraumbehörde
gestrichen und nur 17 der geplanten 20
apollo-missionen konnten stattfinden das alles verstand kosten von mehr als 20 milliarden dollar
wirtschaftlich gesehen gibt es noch heutzutage
diskussionen darüber ob das wirklich notwendig war an dem ganzen apollo-programm waren zudem eine halbe million menschen
beteiligt vier perfekt die apollo-mission fanden statt immer wieder wurden die apollo-missionen von laien in frage gestellt allerdings
verfügten sie nicht über das fachwissen und die optischen und physikalischen kenntnisse die nötig sind um die
video und fotoaufnahmen vom mond zu beurteilen warum sind keine sterne auf den fotos zu sehen warum
wird die amerikanische flagge im wind wieso sind manchmal dieselben hintergründe zu sehen
alles gar nicht mal so komplizierte sachverhalte die aber ohne sachkenntnis
nur schwer verständlich sind wer sich jedoch ein wenig darin vertieft wird alles ziemlich schnell verstehen und umgekehrt
konnte noch niemand nachweisen dass wo und wie die mondlandung hätte inszeniert werden können mit dem damaligen filmischen
möglichkeiten wäre das nämlich schlichtweg unmöglich gewesen selbst kinofilme waren in dieser perfektion nicht möglich und eine so
umfassende dokumentation mit foto film und video hätte wahrscheinlich noch mehr gekostet als eine echte
mondlandung wenn ihr kein video verpassen wollt auch extra videos und livestreams nicht dann werdet mitglied hier auf dem kanal
einfach hier unten wunder draufklicken wir kriegen dann auch noch ein paar
privilegien dazu und unterstützt uns wird einen kleinen betrag einfach
eben auf mitglied werden klicken direkt unter dem video ein riesen dank an all diejenigen die schon dabei sind das macht uns etwas
unabhängiger von den schwankenden werbeeinnahmen hier auf youtube wenn er immer
informiert werden wollt überall aktuellen videos und nicht über die etwas unzuverlässiger box das kennt das schon whatsapp
einfach draufklicken kostet nix und ihr kriegt jeden tag eine meldung wenn das video online geht und zwar sogar etwas früher als hier auf youtube
und am besten auch meine schwester cara klicks um social media abonnieren dafür klicken und nicht die
glocke vergessen und hier geht es war damit dafür auch darauf klickt menschen sollen auf dem mond siedeln bis dann
bleib dran